one of the funniest uh things in your
new special so i watched it with my guy
last night we were
screaming crying uh when uh the idea
about when you're like white families
when something goes wrong in the family
yeah mark's addicted to
meth it's so true yeah they sent out a
newsletter
it's like the premise is like white
families are too honest
you know like they'll be like travis is
addicted to math
and like brown families wouldn't do that
they would spin it they'd be like abdul
cleans the house constantly
it's like because we're all about
keeping up appearances
so like even the wedding thing i was
talking about it's like you have to have
the squeaky clean image there's the
family name
everyone is flawless or at least on the
veneer what is it abdul started a
business oh yeah go where'd your where'd
your tv go abdul started his own
business
[Laughter]
just putting a positive spin on
everything like he sold our tv
tv
he is top salesman
don't donate his teeth to chairs
it's just like it's so like god it's so
funny you're so funny and you're not
like trying to be i just feel like i see
a lot of comedians right now trying to
say something they shouldn't say it's
like there's so much comedy and things
that we all can agree
yeah there's a lot of colors to paint
with sometimes you forget as a con can
we just clip that please there's a lot
of colors to paint with hey that's like
whitney's podcast
now he's gay
but you can get so uh you know
microscopic with you know being the cool
guy and stuff and also okay i've got to
hit these third rails and talk about all
these social issues
but it's just a microphone on a stage
and it's such a blank canvas sometimes
we forget that sometimes i'll do a thing
on the road if i want to keep it
interesting like i have an idea i don't
do it anymore but i had this one bit
where i'm doing some impressions i'm
like this is my impression of a guy at a
concert who's enjoying himself but he
can't completely let go
and then i take my jacket off and i'm
holding it and they play this drake song
and then i'm just kind of like vibing
out like really tiny like super vibing
out
it's just a funny visual with the music
and it's like this set piece that isn't
traditional jokes and it's fun to be
like oh yeah you can do anything it's a
sandbox one of my favorite uh like you
i i i aspire to be one of these people i
don't know if i'm there yet but you are
someone that has
found your thing on social media
in a way that is not embarrassing or
cringy or corny like comedians send
around your videos without making fun of
you which is very that's nice unusual
there's one where you did it was um
an audition your audition for playing
the invisible man
you were playing you know you were
playing a victim of the
yeah because i had just seen the
invisible man the one with elizabeth
yeah yeah
i was laughing i was
laughing about domestic abuse it was so
well just the visual i know it's
supposed to be serious and it's a
serious topic and all that but just
invisible man seeing elizabeth moss get
beat up by nothing
was like hysterical to me i'm like
crying she's just showing off as an
actress at this point yeah i'm like i
know what that guy looks like based on
what you yeah we're supposed to be
scared but i'm just like crying laughing
because nothing is happening to her and
she's so then i had the idea for the
instagram video where i'm like fee anwar
this is um i'm auditioning for the
invisible man and i have sides in my
hand you know i'm in sweatpants at my
house you know and i go
and i put the i think the
camera
and i go
wait a minute so you're telling me
there's some sort of invisible man out
there
and then i just beat myself up like and
then i get up off the ground and i'm
like 5 10 i am rolling the shade
[Music]
foreign
[Music]